la hausse du prix du pétrole remet
également à l'ordre du jour
l'utilisation des énergies renouvelables
depuis le début de l'année le
gouvernement offre des aides sous forme
de crédits d'impôts pour tous les
équipements alternatif c'est notamment
le cas des chauffe eau solaires
les ventes sont cette année en plein
boom reportage en ile de france de
gilles daniel et christian leroux un peu
de soleil et ça suffit pour chauffer
l'eau de toute la maison
ces panneaux noirs des capteurs solaires
se multiplient sur les toits comme ici
en ile de france
une aubaine pour les installateurs
depuis trois ans que nous on sait
chauffe eau solaire nous avions
auparavant une demande tous les trois
mois pour vous donner un petit peu un
ordre de grandeur de la fréquence à
laquelle les gens nous appellent
maintenant c'est que nous avons demande
tous les jours mais ça coûte cher 6400
euros en moyenne depuis le début de
l'année 40 % de l'équipement est déduit
des impôts
cette réduction fiscale a convaincu
bruno aujourd'hui il a fortement réduit
sa facture de fuel et la satisfaction
n'est pas qu'économique
en plus c'est hyper écologique dans le
sang soit on n'émet pas de co2 tout
l'été pour chauffer l'eau chaude il ya
des gens qui laissent leurs chaudières
allumé que pour chauffer de l'eau chaude
l'étais moi je l'éteins fin mais je le
rallume fin septembre les ventes de
chauffe-eau solaires sont en plein boom
8000 ont été installés en france en 2004
et les commandes devraient progresser de
50 à 80 % cette année un phénomène mieux
ancrer dans certains endroits il ya des
régions qui historiquement ont pas mal
développer le solaire je pense à
rhône-alpes et je pense à l'alsace ce
qui montre d'ailleurs au passage qu' on
n'a pas besoin d'être dans une région
très méridionale pour pour faire du
solaire
mais la france est en retard on compte
huit fois moins deux capteurs solaires
qu'en allemagne les aides économiques à
l'installation devrait encore être
renforcés l'an prochain le marché du
solaire a de beaux jours devant lui